jean-luc Picard is back for a new
adventure in Star Trek Picard
once again boldly going where no one has
gone before the CBS all access show is
filled with callbacks to Star Trek past
including some that might allude even
the most dedicated of fans after opening
with a flashback to Picard's resignation
from Starfleet 14 years earlier the
third episode of Picard titled the end
as the beginning finds the erstwhile
Admiral paying a visit to his former
first officer Rafi who was fired from
Starfleet
after Picard resigned Rafi is now living
in a self-described hovel in the Vasquez
rocks where it seems she passes her time
getting high and trying to forget the
years she spent working alongside Picard
however for longtime Star Trek fans the
Vasquez rocks are more than just a cool
location for Rafi to park her 24th
century trailer the Vasquez rocks
Natural Area Park located in the Sierra
pallone a mountains in northern
California has been a frequent shooting
location for past Star Trek productions
including episodes of the original
series the next generation Voyager and
Enterprise along with scenes in the film
Star Trek four of the voyage home JJ
Abrams 2009 Star Trek and its 2013
sequel star trek into darkness as a
matter of fact the Vasquez rocks have
been featured so prominently with in
Star Trek lore that the location has
even been nicknamed Kirk's rock when
Picard meets his new pilot for hire
Cristobal Chris Rios it's under less
than ideal circumstances as Rios is in
the process of having a piece of
titanium shrapnel removed from his
shoulder in order for the emergency
medical hologram to access the injury
Rios is shirtless giving us a clearer
view at the prominent mermaid tattoo on
his upper left arm Ryo ship is named the
La Serena which translates from Spanish
as the mermaid it makes sense that Rios
would have such a strong personal
connection to a ship that he'd want to
permanently mark it on his body but his
choice to name his ship the mermaid
could also be a hint that Rios and
Picard may have more in common than it
might appear
mermaids and mermaid tattoos have long
been associated with a romanticized
image of sailors heading out on perilous
voyages which is how Picard often seem
to view his role as the commander of a
Federation starship this was made plain
by the opening of Star Trek generations
in which Picard and the crew of the
price stepped into their equivalent
roles as officers on a 19th century
naval ship just imagine what it was like
no engines no computers just a win we're
gonna see the stars to guide you rios
embracing of such a classic maritime
symbol may indicate that despite their
apparent differences rios and picard may
in fact be kindred spirits after they
meet picard notices that rios is in the
middle of reading a hardcover version of
the tragic sense of life by miguel
Unamuno written in 1912 it's a
philosophical essay following the author
struggle to reconcile man's pursuit of
wisdom knowledge and reason with his
belief that those pursuits and
consciousness in general actually work
in opposition to leading a happy life
the particular passage that Rios is
reading later on in the episode on page
140 of the book deals with the link
between consciousness and suffering in
which Unamuno muses how do we know that
we exist if we do not suffer little or
much how can we turn upon ourselves
acquire reflective consciousness save by
suffering while Picard hasn't explicitly
shown to be a fan of this author it's
well established that he's a learned
philosophical man Rios interest in
philosophy is yet another clue that the
pilot may have more in common with the
Admiral than meets the eye but the
passage Rios was reading also seems to
point somewhat ominously to the themes
of sentient and personhood that's so
strongly defined Picard unamuno argues
that suffering is essential to
consciousness and that without it we
have no way of knowing that we are truly
alive a philosophy that we may see
revisited as we learn more about dodged
and Saudis origins and the circumstances
leading up to the synthetic uprising
despite Rafi's insistence that she wants
no part of Picard's new mission he sends
her all of the information he has on
Bruce Maddux's research anyway and she
can't help digging into it as Rafi sift
through the files from the DeStorm
Institute there's a brief shot of her
screen on which the words crypto
algorithm identification Gorn egg can be
read the Gorn are a reptilian alien
species first introduced on the classic
Trek episode arena in which Captain Kirk
is transported to the surface of a rocky
planet filmed at the Vasquez rocks by
aliens called the metrans and told he
must battle the captain of an opposing
Gorn ship to the death only the winner
ship and crew will survive
Kirk and the Gorn captain both managed
to injure one another but Kirk
ultimately decides to show mercy and
spare the gorn's life which in turn
leads to both crews being spared by the
metrans at the end of arena the metrans
tell Kirk that while humans are a savage
race there is hope for them due to their
capacity to show mercy to their enemies
inversely the beginning of Picard's
third episode finds Picard and Rafi
lamenting that the Federation is
refusing to show mercy to the Romulans
capitulating instead to intolerance and
fear had Kirk given in to those same
tendencies in arena it would have led to
a far different and more disastrous
outcome despite Rios many personal
similarities to Picard the pilot is
initially reluctant to agree to help the
former Starfleet Admiral when they first
meet later when Rios is alone in his
quarters the emergency medical hologram
appears and attempts to talk Rios into
helping Picard despite his reservations
so are we excited intimidated maybe a
teensy bit starstruck as the EMH runs
down his laundry list of Picard's
accomplishments he mentions that the
cart was chief contact with the Q
continuum which is a reference to both
the pilot episode and series finale of
Star Trek The Next Generation as well as
a number of notable episodes during the
series run the cards encounters with Q
also led to the first introduction of
and subsequent attacks by the Borg he
also mentions that Picard was arbiter of
succession for the Klingon Empire which
was already nodded to in Picard's
premiere episode and that he was captain
of the enterprise D and E a reference
that needs no explanation the EMH wraps
up his exultation of Picard by
name-dropping that he worked alongside
the great Spock calling back to the next
generation episode unification and could
also be a nod to Spock's role in
attempting to prevent the Romulans
supernova as explained in 2009 Star Trek
while most of the cards storyline takes
place on earth all of dodges twin sister
Shoji scenes have been set aboard a
Romulan Reclamation station on a
repurposed Borg Q on which she
encounters an ex Borg drone named
hue-hue first appeared in the next
generation episode i Borg which saw the
Enterprise crew encountered a young Borg
drone who had been abandoned by the
effective although Picard initially sees
the Borg as nothing more than a way to
help him bring down the collective he
ultimately is forced to recognize his
sentient in personhood when the drone
begins exhibiting signs of individuality
and gives himself the name Hugh I will
not assist you few pops up again in the
two-part TNG episode descent where it is
revealed that after rejoining the
collective his sense of individuality
spread to his entire cube and they were
cut off from the collective in descent
Hugh proved himself a loyal ally of
Picard in the enterprise rescuing
several members of the crew and
resisting datas megalomaniacal brother
lure him it's hard to predict what's in
store for Hugh on Picard but if Hugh's
past history with the Admiral are any
indication he may prove to be an
important albeit unexpected Ally for
Picard and his rogue crew check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]